know who would be like your top five
current wide receivers other than Mike
Evans
Oh I thought she's about to ask me like
underrated wide receivers underrated
they could be underrated
I hate doing that top five because it's
so hard but do the top five do the top
five
right now I do top five current right
now and then he said not not include
myself
we'll go uh Devonte Adams
digs
J Jets
Tyree Hill
is it more Chase
Jamal Chase for sure what about the top
five underrated
wide receivers Scary Terry Terry McLaren
is is the most underrated receiver in
the league I think he's so tough
um
Chris Godwin is super underrated
he's a beast
it's hard there's so many guys that are
underrated in the league
um
let's go Gabe Davis
player man physical
High Point the ball contest the catch
run after catch
um of course we got
is Mike Williams underrated
I feel like people talk about Mike
Williams a lot though
I think outside of the football world
outside of the football World they
probably don't talk about as much yeah
we know I know about Michael he was in
the division he has an injury he has an
ankle injury right now but
man he's he's just rocks are getting
better every year he hops he's one of
the best contested catch guys High Point
guys in the league if not the best High
Point guy
um
who else we got so many other guys
Justin Watson Kansas City Chiefs my
former teammate he's number 84. he's
super underrated
he's having a great season this year
called some touchdowns this year man
he's having his best year